welcome back we'll now do another
tension problem and this one is just a a
slight increment harder than the
previous one just because we have to uh
uh take out our slightly more
sophisticated algebra tools than we did
in the last one but but it's not really
uh any any harder but you should
actually see this type of problem
because you'll probably see it on an
exam
so let's figure out the tension in the
wire so first of all we know that
this point right here isn't moving so
the tension in this little small wire
right here is easy it's it's trivial
it's the force of gravity is pulling
down at this point with 10 newtons right
because you have this weight here and of
course since this point is stationary
the tension in this wire has to be 10
newtons upward that's an easy one so
let's just figure out the tension in
these two slightly more difficult wires
to figure out the tensions of
so once again we know that this point
right here
this point is not accelerating in any
direction right it's not accelerating in
the x direction
nor is it accelerating in the vertical
direction or the y direction so we know
that the net forces in the x direction
need to be zero on it and we know that
the net forces in the y direction need
to be zero right
so what are the net forces in the x
direction well they're going to be the x
components of these two of the of the of
the tension vectors of both of these
wires so let's i guess let's draw the
tension vectors of the two wires
okay so this t1
it's pulling the tension vector pulls in
the direction of the wire along the same
line so let's say that this is the
tension vector of t1
if that's the tension vector
its x component will be this let me
see how good i can draw this
it's intended to be a straight line but
that would be its x component and its x
component let's see this is 30 degrees
this is 30 degrees right here
and hopefully this is a bit second
nature to you what is if this value up
here is t1 what is the value of the x
component
it's t1 cosine of 30 degrees
t 1
cosine
of 30 degrees
and you could do your sohcahtoa you know
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse right
so the cosine of 30 degrees is equal to
this
over t1 is equal to the x component over
t1 and if you multiply both sides by t1
you get this this should be a little bit
of second nature right now that the x
component is going to be the cosine of
the angle between the hypotenuse and the
x component times the hypotenuse
and similarly the x component here let
me
draw this force vector so if this is t2
if that's t2
this would be its x component
and very similarly this is 60 degrees
so this would be t2
cosine
of 60.
now what do we know about these two
vectors
we know that when you
that their net force is zero or that you
also know that the magnitude of these
two vectors should cancel each other out
or that they're equal i mean we they're
pulling in opposite directions that's
that's pretty obvious but and so you
know that their magnitudes need to be
equal so we know that t1 cosine of 30 is
going to equal t2 cosine of 60. so let's
write that down
t1
cosine
of 30 degrees
is equal to
t2
cosine of 60
and then we could we could bring the t2
onto this side and actually let's also
i'm trying to save as much space as
possible because i'm guessing this is
going to take up a lot of room this
problem what's the cosine of 30 degrees
if you haven't memorized it already
square root of 3 over 2. so this becomes
square root of 3 over 2 times t1 right
that's the cosine of 30 degrees and then
i'm going to bring this onto this side
so the cosine of 60 degrees
the cosine of 60 degrees is actually one
half
you could use your calculator if you
forgot that so this is one half t2 i'm
going to bring it on this side so it
becomes minus one half
i'm skipping more steps than normal just
because i don't want to waste
too much space and this equals zero but
if you've seen the other videos
hopefully i'm not i'm not
creating too many gaps and and this is
relatively easy to follow
so we have the square root of 3 times t1
minus 1 half square
t2 is equal to 0. so that gives us an
equation one equation with two unknowns
so it doesn't help us much so far but
let's let's uh square that away because
i have a feeling this will be useful
now what's going to be happening on the
y components so let's say that this is
the y component of t1
and this is the y component of t2
what do we know what what do we know
about the two y i could have drawn them
here too and then just shift them over
to the left and the right we know that
their combined
pull upwards the combined pull of the
the two vertical tension ones has to
offset the force of gravity right
pulling down because this point is
stationary so we know these two y
components when you add them together
hat the combined tension in the vertical
direction has to be 10 newtons right
because it's offsetting this force of
gravity
so what's this y component well similar
that this was t1 of cosine of 30 this
should start to become a little second
nature to you that this is t1 sine of 30
this y component right here
so
t1
let me write it here
t
sine
of 30 degrees
plus
this vector which is t 2
sine of 60 degrees
sine of 60 you could review your
trigonometry in your circuit this is
that that tends to be frankly i think
what you know just seeing what people
get confused on is the trigonometry but
you can review the trig modules and
maybe some of the earlier force vector
modules that we did and hopefully this
these will make sense i'm skipping a few
steps
and these will equal 10 newtons
10 newtons
and let's rewrite this up here where i
substitute the values so what's the sine
of 30 actually let me
let me just do it right here what's the
sine of 30 degrees the sine of 30
degrees is one half so we get
one half
t
one
plus the sine of sixty degrees which is
square root of three over two
square root of three over two t 2
is equal to 10.
and i don't like this all these twos and
these one have just one half here so
let's multiply this whole equation by 2.
so 2 times 1 half that's
1. so you get t 1
plus the square root of 3
t 2
is equal to
2 times 10 is 20.
so let's take this equation up here and
let's multiply this equation
by 2 and bring it down here
so this original one we've got so if we
multiply this whole thing by 2
i would do it in this color so that you
know that it's a
different equation so if you multiply
square root of 3 over 2 times 2. i'm
just doing this to get rid of the 2's in
the denominator so you get square root
of 3
oops square root of 3
t
minus
t 2
is equal to 0 right because 0 times 2 is
0.
and let's see what we could do what if
we take this top equation because we
want to start canceling out some terms
let's take this top equation and
multiply it let's multiply it by
oh i don't know the minus
let's multiply it by
let's multiply it by the square root of
3 so you get square root of 3
t 1
right i'm taking this top equation
multiplied by square root of 3 this is
just a system of equations i'm solving
for
and the square root of 3 times this
right here square root of 3 times square
root of 3 is 3
so plus
t 2 is equal to 20
square roots of 3.
and now what i want to do is
let's
let's i know i'm doing a lot of the
equation manipulation here but this is
just hopefully a review of algebra for
you let's subtract
this equation from this equation
right so you can also view it as
multiplying it by negative 1 and then
adding the 2. so when you subtract this
from this these two terms cancel out
right because they're the same
and so then you're left with
minus
t2 from here minus this
minus 3
t 2
is equal to 0
minus 20 square roots of 3.
and so this becomes minus 4
t 2
is equal to minus 20
square roots of three
and then divide both sides by minus four
and you get t two
is equal to
five
square roots of three so newtons
so that's the tension in this wire and
now we can substitute and figure out t1
so let's let's let's do it let's use
this formula right here because it looks
suitably simple
so we have the square root of 3 times t1
minus t2 well t2 is 5 square roots of 3
right
5 square roots of 3
is equal to 0 so we have the square root
of 3 t 1
is equal to 5 square roots of 3. divide
both sides by square root of three and
you get the tension and the first wire
is equal to five newtons
so this is pulling with the force of
or tension of five newtons or force
and this is pulling the second wire with
a tension of
5 squares of 3
newtons so this
this wire right here is actually doing
more of the pulling it's actually more
of the force of gravity is ending up on
this wire and that that makes sense
because it's steeper so since it's
deeper it has it's kind of it's
contributing more to the the y component
it's good whenever you do these problems
to kind of do a reality check just to
make sure your your numbers make sense
and if you think about their combined
tension their combined tension is
something more than 10 newtons and that
makes sense because some of their some
of the force that they're pulling with
is wasted against pulling each other in
the horizontal direction
anyway i'll see you all in the next
video